en métropole et en outre-mer merci
madame pompili la parole et à monsieur
alain gest
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
lorsqu'on analyse objectivement la
situation économique de notre pays
secteur par secteur
on constate que celui de l'industrie va
mal depuis 2012 la situation s'est
particulièrement dégradée
preuve en est entre 2012 et 2016 600
sites industriels ont vu le jour alors
que dans le même temps ce sont 900
usines qui ont fermé leurs portes
hormis deux trimestres est légèrement
positif en 2016 l'érosion est continue
depuis l'élection de françois hollande
cent soixante dix mille emplois ont
disparu la région des hautes france a
été particulièrement frappé par cette
dégradation et une rumeurs insistantes
évoquent maintenant la possible
fermeture de l'usiné whirpool damien
dernière unité de production du groupe
américain en france ce sont environ 350
employés permanents et personnels du
sous-traitant installé au sein même du
site qui vivent dans une situation de
profonde inquiétude
les signes ne trompent pas depuis le
rachat par whirpool dean dsit des postes
clés en cdi remplacés par des cdd une
érosion régulière du nombre de salariés
la volonté de transférer la production
dans deux usines de pologne
une direction qui ne dément pas les
rumeurs la démission récente du
directeur et j'en passe nous pourrions
être dans un cas typique de
délocalisation
ce serait un nouveau drame économique et
social pour la somme et amiens monsieur
le premier ministre il y à une good year
amiens ensuite payé le prix de votre
réforme territoriale notamment par la
perte de son statut de capitale
régionale et par la fuite d'emplois
publics sans compensation à ce jour si
la menace se confirme nous sommes en
droit d'attendre de la part de l'état un
acte fort
alors quelles sont les informations dont
vous disposez aujourd'hui et que comptez
vous faire
merci la parole est à monsieur
christophe sirugue secrétaire d'état
chargé de l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs le député monsieur le député
alain gest des interrogations et des
inquiétudes pèsent effectivement suite
aux annonces qui ont été faites et
reprise par la presse de changement à la
tête de l'entreprise whirlpool france
également du site d'amiens que vous
mentionnez elle pose bien sûr la
question de savoir quelle signification
il faut en tirer par rapport à
l'implantation même de walpole sur le
site d'amiens vous l'avez mentionné
cette entreprise salary près de 300
salariés et par ailleurs produit des
sèche-linge plutôt de haut de gamme qui
participe bien sûr à d'un environnement
économique intéressant dans un
territoire dont vous avez dit en effet
qu'il a connu des restructurations
difficile mais aussi je veux leur
rappeler des implantations intéressante
je pense à amazon très récemment
il n'en demeure pas moins que les
éléments dont nous disposons ont amené
le gouvernement à se mobiliser de
manière très rapide pour interpeller les
responsables de whirpool je les aurai
moi même au téléphone d'ici la fin de la
journée pour échanger avec eux sur les
intentions qui sont celles du groupe par
rapport au site d'amiens il y a bien
évidemment une responsabilité qui est
celle du groupe que d'informer à la fois
les organisations syndicales les
salariés mais aussi les pouvoirs publics
des intentions qui sont les leurs et
j'entends bien leur rappeler à la fois
les responsabilités économiques et
sociales qui sont les leurs pour que
nous puissions imaginer ensemble une
réponse qui puisse être apportée le cas
échéant s'il devait y avoir une annonce
de fermeture qui pour l'instant n'est
pas confirmé mais qui bien évidemment
fait partie des inquiétudes qui sont
portées sur le territoire je veux vous
dire monsieur le député combien il est
essentiel car sur ces questions
industrielles soit interpellé le projet
industriel bien évidemment et que le cas
échéant une mobilisation de l'ensemble
des pouvoirs publics va fait pour que
nous puissions permettre de d'avoir un
territoire qu'ils sachent répondre aux
difficultés auxquelles il est tôt